Actualmente
como precandidata por el partido verde animalista de cara
a este período electoral,
por qué tomaste esta decisión de
de bueno dar este paso,
no de tratar de buscar un lugar
por lo menos a a nivel del Parlamento.
Bueno, en principio
porque estamos tratando de darle un perfil al partido verde
animalista que ya compitió en las elecciones pasadas
con un perfil totalmente distinto,
lo que lo que no tenía en ese momento el partido verde
animalista era animalismo.
No, no había una reivindicación fuerte del animalismo.
Nosotros en realidad
tratamos de bueno vamos a competir en estas elecciones
internas. En principio para darle un perfil de herramienta
partir Daria para el activismo político que venimos haciendo.
Nosotros sostenemos que lo animal es político,
es una discusión política.
Acá la mesa se está discutiendo
algo que tiene que ver con lo político,
porque no es solamente
el animal como a quien le gustan los animales,
sino que es una cuestión
de justicia que tiene que ver con educación,
que tiene que ver con la sociedad
en cuanto a violencia sí o violencia no,
si se fomenta o no se fomenta,
son discusiones políticas,
que es que nosotros somos animales,
los humanos somos animales y los animales
políticos y por lo tanto
hay que trabajar en términos de convivencia responsable
y esto implica por supuesto cuidado de la naturaleza,
que es nuestro hábitat, donde nosotros podemos vivir
y eso es para los individuos sintientes,
para todos los individuos sintientes
Las internas tenés 2 2 vertientes,
me dijiste. No, sí, sí.
Por un lado nosotros como agrupación desafío
la agrupación 409,
vamos a estar proponiendo este cambio
de Timón, si se quiere,
de de rumbo hacia una visión más de convivencia responsable
eh animalista, teniendo en cuenta también al animal humano.
Y bueno, y está la agrupación
que eh tiene un perfil más ambientalista.
Y bueno, sigue quizá algunos otros lineamientos,
lineamientos diferentes.
El ecologismo y el animalismo
tratan de convivir adentro del partido verde animalista,
desde el punto de vista de que la defensa de la naturaleza
es necesaria para la vida sintiente.
El problema es cuando nosotros pensamos
en el ecologismo como la defensa de la naturaleza
como recurso recurso para la explotación humana,
que esa es una visión totalmente diferente,
porque ahí también entran los animales como recurso.
De hecho.
¿Por qué creo que no hay una reivindicación de estos temas
adentro de los demás partidos?
¿Y por qué es necesario un partido animalista?
Porque se toca en campaña,
pero en realidad no se profundiza nunca.
Hoy tenemos un ministerio de ambiente que se creó,
saludamos que se haya creado,
pero no está funcionando prácticamente.
Tenemos también una flexibilización de la casa por
por decreto presidencial,
sí tenemos un invacreado,
afortunadamente un invacreado,
que fue un avance en torno a lo que era la la cotriba,
pero no puede gestionar denuncias
y sin embargo
siguen faltando cosas y sigue sin profundizarse.
Yo quisiera saber
y lo voy a
Leer con mucha atención
en el programa de gobierno de todos los partidos
qué hay de animalismo real,
¿de defensa de la convivencia
responsable y respetuosa con los demás animales?